here we are anime North just found
parking luckily hey guys it's Anna Mac
and I clearly I'm cosplaying as a random
extra from [ __ ] oh yeah that's an
airplane because we're right by the
airport in Toronto
so bright today around
they pronounced in the book handle if
you're a launch mojo fab that you
probably won't recognize 80% of the
anime references we're going to look at
that I hope these aren't lines I hope
they're just like John's or line
you
so Anna Mac freaked out and I freaked
out softly all our battery and memory
was pointless line related like we were
god we were past the one - it was like
12 it was like security guard and then
the animatic just comes from the road
but is it go away at all we got
you have to go another way now
but whatever at least ride those guys
over there that this that's its king
Pikachu
yeah man thou art so fab believe it and
we are AC guys
what's cool is about everyone like nice
one style to talk everyone
laws are you love yeah I felt like Comic
Con just to watch a douchebag
see guys I like comic-con there's only a
small portion of anime I really care
about comics so
much better
there's I wonder where that away
all babies are cute
some are do mangoes think
Merida
and a box a big fan photo and all of the
izaki spell
one punch so look up look out for Animax
one punch review coming out soon you
might have been five odds out there you
know
explain to me how that works I would
help I don't think it so it you could
hold it to be like I'm gonna review this
show all right I will have to show this
the coke I look at all seven dragonballs
you gathered it for us thank you that
was these the only hundred twenty
dollars yeah I mean it saves you a lot
of like lights around the world right
articles soft like mouth I've explained
was there between light novels in manga
I don't know
rising the other hole
I feel like I'll just I'll just say
[ __ ]
go away guys
12 times late
apparently
dawn dawn dawn
the Superman you don't belong here
Superman
Goku could kick your ass
probably getting his lunch out people
still don't recognize them because you
know these us level seer a superhero
people don't really give a [ __ ] all
right guys
all right
pretty much it's about I don't know like
4:30 right now we came at 7 a.m. we're
pretty [ __ ] tired sorry about the
wind it's probably gonna be loud but
because it was fun and I got a kunai to
remember today hey guys so it's a really
hot day and while we wait for the car to
like stop being a sauna
I thought we'd uh recap some water
experiences today you know it was our
first visit to anime north and it was
really uh no overwhelming experience you
have all these like so many people like
I would say tens of thousands of people
over a huge area many hotels Convention
Center you go in there they're selling
everything there's so much to do so much
to see I'm really an overwhelming
experience especially since our first
time but if you're an anime fan
definitely recommend to check it out
there yeah guys a hot tiring day but
definitely a fun one and definitely
worth it we'll definitely go with the
next year's one as well and we're
definitely gonna say definitely every
other word yeah we're not going to put
that in the file cut that's okay you
better put it especially you saying
we're gonna we're definitely not gonna
put in the final uncut
that's why not
alright guys now we're got a long drive
home as always until next time see you
space catalyst
you